ladies and gentlemen director james
mangold what's that called again to
catch box yeah so we throw this at the
audience and they can ask questions and
it comes through the speakers wow that's
that's how IMAX of you right so before
we get started I want to give a huge
thank you to IMAX for being an awesome
sponsor that's a huge thank you to 20
Century Fox Carol over there thank you
for letting us screen the movie before
it was in theaters so I seriously huge
thank you and thanks to all of you guys
for coming out on a weeknight to see the
movie thank you before we started by the
way so um it was pretty good
presentation here wasn't it yeah just
just making sure yeah so Before we jump
into first of all thank you so much for
doing this QA thank you I like doing
these things with you Steve he's fun you
know the last time we did one was Logan
that's the last movie I made exactly I'm
just saying I that's I supposed to do
one in between you know but I wanted to
just say that it's one of my favorite q
and A's that I've ever done because you
were just awesome in terms of breaking
down the superhero genre what you liked
what you had it was just a great QA and
so I just want to thank you for the last
one thank you I have a few fun questions
before we get into your fantastic movie
because we'll see if they're fun in two
minutes what TV show would you love to
guest direct well Game of Thrones what
would have been the answer until until
it stopped okay what movie do you think
you've seen the most there's a there's a
group of them sweet smell of success
thank you all the President's Men
it's a wonderful life Jaws alien a whole
series of westerns floating weeds a lot
of oohs ooh films I mean there's a kind
of there's stuff I watch repetitiously
almost as a kind of just reminder black
narcissus Michael Powell film I could
keep going but I couldn't think of one
do you remember what it was when you
were growing up that first made you fall
in love with movies and what was it if
you can remember that maybe flip the
switch in your head that said I want to
do that well I mean the first one which
Star Wars was a religious experience for
me when I saw it at 13 or 14 when I saw
it I it was I was on a trip with my aunt
and uncle to see Yellowstone Park and
they lived in Chicago I lived in New
York and I saw I flew to Chicago to meet
up on my aunt and uncle and my uncle
took us to see Star Wars at a big
theater in Chicago the day before we
left to Yellowstone and then we had two
weeks camping out and the point of
saying this is that I don't remember
anything about Yellowstone all I did was
called my parents from Old Faithful and
say like you have to see this movie and
the that I loved movies before that I
mean I was I was already making films
with my dad super 8 camera but that
movie and and of course growing up at
that moment the culture was Steven
Spielberg George all that whole world of
these twenty eight to thirty two year
olds making these movies was
mind-blowing and the other the other
funny story I have were a alien had a
similar effect was a couple years later
but I saw it on opening day in New York
alone in a theater I went to like the
10:00 a.m. show at the Loews 84th
whatever and the here's a bars yes and
and I was alone in the theater and I
didn't know what the movie was
and it scared the [ __ ] out of me and and
riding home I got the two had the joy of
telling a story to Ridley Scott a couple
years ago but a riding home there was
some talk radio guy my dad was listening
to and he was on ABC talk radio and he
was saying what a piece of [ __ ] the
movie was and and that the Eddie was
saying the monster is even scary man and
I was like going nuts in my parents car
going what are you talking about I ran
home and this was day of rotary dials
and I dialed the WABC talk radio number
a thousand times from my parents attic
and got online on the air and and the
guy who hears Jim from Washington Villa
wants to talk about alien what a piece
of [ __ ] Jim and and I was like it was
not and he's like yes it was that
creature looked like the Cookie Monster
and I was like no it didn't and he was
like goodbye Jim that was my radio my my
early radio appearance that is amazing I
went to Jim we're about to get into your
movie but what have you ever watched a
TV show all the way through more than
once no I mean except for when I was
eight I probably seen every season of
Gilligan's Island The Brady Bunch
I Dream of Jeannie and I mean that stuff
yes but but no in recent life no I think
once once is enough what was the last
thing that you were really obsessed with
Fame it could be like a book a movie it
could be a play I mean collecting I go
through phases with music so so but I I
can't tell you because it would it would
give away what I'm working on
does it have to do with a large cat no I
think I can't remember the title but I
heard that there was a movie it's in
development but no it has nothing to do
with that one no now let's jump into why
I get to talk to you tonight as I've
said repeatedly I love this movie so
much
i I'm gonna fish for the audience but
did you guys enjoy this thank you what
was it
obviously you you're an in-demand
filmmaker what was it about this project
that said this is what I'm gonna do
after Logan
I've been chasing it since before Logan
and since before even the Wolverine
before that in fact the meeting I went
on at Fox where they handed me Chris
McQuarrie script for the Wolverine was
the meeting in which I went in to talk
about this movie and the challenge with
movies like this it was it was another
team was working on it and I was not
welcome and the but the but the reality
is the reason it's so hard to get movies
like this made is that it's not you know
what they call them business IP it's not
pre-existing trademarked stuff where
there's a there's a pre-sold audience
it's gonna show up to see this character
or this world in this movie and so when
that's the case the studios are very
nervous about spending too much money on
a movie like that you know what we used
to just call an original movie and and
so what that results in is that when you
have a movie like this there were
there's no real way to do it without
spending dough meaning you can't just
creating the races and the cars and the
period it's not going to be cheap and so
the movie gets stuck in a way luckily
for me it got stuck and that no one
would pull the green light on it because
they couldn't figure out how to make it
affordable enough or they want to take
the risk on it and what basically
happened is I would check in between
every movie about this property and this
material and after Logan it was free and
I got together with Jazz Butterworth and
John Henry Butterworth and we kept
working on the script part of it was to
get it to where we could afford to make
it and and also just there were ways I
wanted to shape the script I loved the
characters I loved I'm not a big motor
sports guy in fact I'm the opposite like
I don't think I've ever successfully
watched a race
from beginning end except this one and
the and but that even gave what I loved
and identified with was the was the
world of getting these cars on the road
seemed a lot like my life like like
getting movies made and and I found the
characters really inspiring that they
kind of really can miles is this kind of
perfectionist who I really identify with
who is is is kind of isn't really
thinking rationally gets himself in
trouble with taxes in any way he's just
in pursuit of he's an artist in a sense
and and Shelby is a kind of slightly
more interesting figure and that he's a
Salesman he's also an artist but he's
kind of a Salesman and so there's this
kind of interesting dialectic going on
between these two characters who admire
each other but both are kind of not
exactly in the same philosophical place
and you when you're looking for a movie
you're essentially always looking you
have to be where I am the movies are
simple in a sense they they have to work
on a very primal level they also need a
cinematic idea like making a movie about
what I just described isn't good enough
meaning it would be my dinner with Andre
you know be just two people sitting
around talking about their life
perspectives unless you can find a way
to take these ideas about art versus
Commerce and and perfection versus
compromise and pursuit of excellence and
and how do you and that the world of a
racing film or a sports film gives you a
framework to make something entertaining
and engrossing and dynamic out of it
where even the cars then become you know
metaphors and interesting elements I
mean all that and then it's it's a cars
of a beautiful relationship with the
movie camera you know and
so all that was in the mix of why I was
attracted to it and I just kept stalking
the movie until I log in maybe just
because of the success of Logan but it
suddenly had become free enough that
that I could jump in you so you get you
sit down to rework the script to get it
down to a budget that is something film
about how much when you're reworking the
script are you thinking about casting
and or is it sort of like we got to get
the script down and that's like the most
important thing you're thinking about
all of it but you don't have a movie
without the people so from the moment I
get involved in fact I probably most of
the effort to get that money down was
happening after I had Kristian and Matt
involved meaning that the the I would
have no chance of getting the studio to
make this movie unless I had stars any
of some kind so that there it just
wouldn't happen like even if I could get
the money down without Kristian and Matt
the money would have to go down further
and that because they're just looking
for an angle on how to get your butt
into a theater and without stars and
without being able to say it's a Marvel
character or a Star Wars character or
Terminator character or any whatever it
is they they're there's so many the
tokens that they'd normally get to spend
to get you out to the theater um that
they don't have that known actors are
one of the few remaining they have and
so in a way the budget was determined by
who I out in the movie and luckily the
first two people I asked jumped in Matt
I mean listen you you those two are two
of the best actors working how tough
what is it like sitting down I mean
you've worked with Bale before what is
it like do you still get nervous like
the night before you're gonna sit down
with them to talk about the project like
man I really want them to be like I need
them I want them or is it sort of like
do you know what I mean what you do a
little but it works I mean it's kind of
works differently in the sense that it
really is all about the script so you
get nervous to get the script right
before you send it to them and then you
send it to them because at least this is
the truth for me they I but and these
certainly these two guys they know who I
am and they know my work and I name the
case of both of them I've known them
for almost 20 years so in this
particular case I'm not nervous about
screwing up the meeting so much as I
have a feeling they're probably gonna
know whether they're doing the movie or
not before they show up
meaning if they've read the script and
they know me it's kind of like the but
the other way you think about is once
you're doing the meeting and they've
read the script
you kind of know you've almost got them
you can only [ __ ] it up like it's like
like if they're coming
no no actor wants to go on a meeting on
a movie where they're waiting for the
director to talk them into doing it
meaning it's it can happen but usually
they have to be they have to see it in
some way they have to feel it or else
they're gonna need you to talk them into
it every day meaning they need to get it
themselves so if you don't mind do you
remember what it was like that first
time you talked to two Bale and Damon
and maybe some of the questions they had
about anything or with what was those
first conversations like Matt was really
really simple he very cut and dry
questions about the script and very very
very dry simple questions about how some
things he missed or he thought we could
use or whatever but wasn't he liked the
script a lot Christian too liked the
script a lot so I but if you want to
kind of know about the process with them
it's you know it becomes a kind of
long-term year long or longer exchange
of ideas each actor Matt and Christian
have different ways of communicating
Matt will do it more often kind of
hanging out talking Christian you'll get
these wonderful I think Christian will
do that too but but you'll get these
wonderful kind of stream of
consciousness emails about what he's
been thinking about and researching and
and each of them have a kind of their
own way and and of offering you their
psyche their instincts I mean if you can
recognize it you know one of the biggest
things I've come to feel you know I
teach directing sometimes and one of the
things I feel like it's hardest for
younger directors to embrace is the idea
of taking ideas from your collaborators
that that and and I don't think as
filmmakers we help because when we do
our press we try our best to make it
look like everything was in our heads
before the movie started so that every
young filmmaker thinks they need to have
everything in their head the envisioned
like the almost the question like was
all like I'll get in situations like
this I'll get a question like did you
see this all exactly this way in advance
and of course the tremendous
gravitational pull of your ego is a yes
you know but it's a lie of course that
the that that the the the biggest thing
I learned I've learned making movies is
that they look better when you take
advantage of what's happening as opposed
to what you brought only you know it's
like life you're like everything is
better when you're actually listening
and watching and not living inside your
head so that the the this idea of
arriving with with with everything
preset is is flattering but and you
certainly arrive with an agenda but it
is in that dialogue that I mean I could
give you examples of how I discovered
this making this movie a long time
Copland we're in the first week I was I
was directing the movie and and when I'd
ride home from dailies they'd give you
this manila envelope with all the stills
from the set that the stills guy had
taken during that week and I was looking
at all the stills guys stills on the
first week of shooting and they all look
better than any in the frames I was
making and what was the difference the
difference was I had my storyboards and
I had figured it out and this is how it
was covered and I knew I was gonna shoot
it this way and so that I did it but he
just had a camera and he saw sly
standing there and Bob De Niro standing
there and he found this great angle here
and it was like he was living in the
moment
using the white and the moment and the
way the light was falling on the
buildings the way these actors looked on
that day
and where they ended up with blocking
and I out of fear of like I if I leave
my little shot list I'll lose my nap you
know my triple a map of getting through
the day that I wasn't looking and so
it's the big lesson for me in every
instance with collaborators and my crew
with my actors with everything is be
listening they have great ideas and and
it's easy to say no to them you just say
no I don't want to do that but but it's
incredible how many directors shut down
the dialogue before it even starts and
and don't get the benefit of all these
other ideas one of the things that I
commend you for is in all your movies I
think you bring out such great
performances from your actors and you
told me recently that you've got like a
little advice from Robert De Niro on
Copland that really changed the way I
guess maybe approach with that he well
he was um he had this process when he
decided to do a role in Copland he had
this process where he he was just invite
I lived near him and we had a couple
reasons I think he kind of was curious
about me in a friendly or paternal way
well both our dads were painters fine
artists in New York he lived not far
from where I lived in in lower Manhattan
and but he would ask me over without
kind of a what I could perceive as an
agenda other than hanging out and then
he would be like well when we read
through what's read through the script
and and so then it would just be me and
him with ginger tea reading through my
whole screenplay with me playing
everyone that he wasn't playing and and
first of all you get this moment of
going like I'm doing scenes with Bob De
Niro in his house with ginger tea which
is all very cool but uh but the other
part is he just makes you what I
realized he was doing was just hanging
out and getting used to each other and
that there was a point at which he said
to me you know I don't work with I
haven't worked with a lot of young
directors and he goes the reason why is
they're all like in awe of me and he
goes and I I need the director to tell
me stuff like so I don't
want you to be shy and he goes so when
I'm doing the scene tell me what you
need and he goes I don't mean after you
say cut I mean before you say cut while
it's still rolling in fact your voice
won't even bother me while I'm acting if
you just shout at me what you need and
and I was like okay and and then we
started shooting and I did what he said
which is if I felt like he was off I go
take that again coming in whatever I
just something brief but I and he loved
it and he'd attack the scene again and I
saw this was particularly his process is
that Bob kind of gets in a zone and he
doesn't want when you say cut on a movie
you know all these people descend with
their combs and their blowers and their
their tape and they're measuring and the
end and there's all this reset and if
you're an actor and you're kind of in in
in it all that can fall out of you you
know all that can you can lose the scene
while people are making all their stuff
perfect and you can lose whatever that
churned up moment you're kind of feeling
it it's like a wave and you're riding
and then it's gone so and Bob taught me
that I can be of help in keeping even
someone like that someone that esteemed
I can be of assistance and he's looking
for me to be of assistance to him to
keep him in the zone to demand more of
him
and that was the first month I was
shooting that movie and so when Bob De
Niro was acting that way and inviting
that kind of dialogue with me then you
have Sly Stallone and Ray Liotta and
Harvey Keitel and all these other guys
on the set who are watching little bub
in this guy really a good thing going
you know and and suddenly they're all
like yeah tell me what do you need and
so suddenly he set this tone for
everyone you know on the movie that was
Jim's cool do what he says and and and
that movie I mean can you imagine
entering a movie you know you're like 30
years old you have Bob De Niro Harvey
Keitel Ray Liotta Pete Berg who am i
leaving out the entire cast of this
future Sopranos and the and and they're
all it was easy
you know they were they were lovely and
it was really about Bob teaching you to
get mess to me what the lesson was sorry
for rambling was about get in the dirt
with me don't talk to me like I'm a
specimen or some kind of strange exotic
alien or creature don't use a special
language just act with me you know like
like get in here and do this scene with
me how you know and and that combined
with other lessons I've gotten along the
way has been really useful in terms of I
can't tell you how many because I've
taught a lot that how many younger film
sets I've seen where the actors are over
there and the crews over here and and a
rehearsal is kind of for a young
director the scary moment you have to
talk to these people and they have ideas
and and and it's all and yet hanging out
with your DP and your tech friends is
all fine with your American
cinematographer magazines and yeah yeah
but yeah but no stress here but when I
have to deal with them very stressful
and it's like why what part of the
reason they're over there is because you
put them over there you know why don't
you why aren't you with them and I don't
know how to explain it for those of you
do any of these things I'm talking about
maybe you'll recognize what I'm talking
about but it's a really it's a really
important thing I think to find your
friendship with the actors before you
even start to ask for anything else
you're kind of your language some kind
of vernacular between you that allows
you to do what is really an intimate
dance you know for a long period four
months Bale and Damon and all your
supporting characters and even the
background people in this are tremendous
talk a little bit about being on set
with everyone and maybe how you've
changed as a director or it's from
Copland did that sort of I guess I'm
curious what is what do you like on set
now and two because you managed to shape
these great performances well I'd have
to ask someone else what I'm like to get
a really good objective answer but the
I think I'm pretty I think I do whatever
it takes to get the scene I'd say and
most of that is about bringing a lot of
times just energy enthusiasm a kind of
sense of I feel like I'm responsible for
the momentum of what can nothing is
worse than a movie set in sludge that
kind of enters this kind of slogging and
that it's it's best identified I think
by the way I see what I do besides
trying to figure out how the scenes
gonna be blocked and how it's gonna be
edited in what shots I need to do that
I'm also trying to make sure that what's
and what ends up in those shots is not
just a kind of perfunctory moment but
something indescribably delicate now I
can't or we're interesting and I can't
always make that happen but it's I'm
chasing I sometimes call it like a
feather in the wind you're chasing
chasing this take where something
happens it is indescribable that you're
chasing the perfect lap yes yes and but
but it is indescribable meaning to me
perfect cinema is when cinema is doing
the thing that nothing else can do what
is the thing cinema can do that nothing
else can do it can read an actor's mind
it can get inside their mind you could
argue that happens on the stage but no
it doesn't you're too far away and it's
too presentational it's not the same the
lens is here and there's no faking it
and they don't even have to on stage
there's no it's and the theater is a
different tradition the cinema is a
tradition of looks and glances first
speech second the theater is a tradition
of speech first and that the that I'm
chasing that thing between the words
that moment that flicker that's
something that is you cannot coach per
se you're just in you're in pursuit of
this thing and and so what I bring to
the set is a kind of
whatever energy is required evangelical
energy determined energy passionate
energy critical energy whatever is
required to try and get it because the
an actor may not may feel I was bossy or
difficult or demanding one day but they
will be much more angry if their work is
[ __ ] meaning they'll really resent that
I've had plenty of actors where I've
pushed and that we've been and we've had
crosswords or we pissed each other off
but the thing is that they'll forgive me
for in a second if they're good in the
scene if they're not good in the scene
and I was really polite they will never
work with me again so the the reality is
that it's all about the work and and in
any way because it's what lives forever
and gets strung around our necks one way
or another we have to live looking at it
and and having made mistakes and movies
and you like you can never watch the
movie and I go why didn't I why did I
you know and now with Twitter I have
seventy thousand million people going
why did he and you're like you're right
why did I
[Music]
I know I know your first cut was a lot
longer but I'm gonna share it with the
audience talk a little about your first
cut versus the finished film well every
movie I make longer director's cut
I think of this well well the way you
were used word director's cut it would
imply I had a cut that was mine and was
finished as that someone made me cut it
shorter so no I mean believe me they
would have loved this to be shorter than
that the I haven't had an issue with a
cut that way for years but the I mean
Copland yes I mean that was a brutal
process and there's a been movies where
it's more difficult but that's not the
case in the last few years but the the
when you say director's cut it's more
this way they market blu-rays with its
extra [ __ ] it was my not the proper way
I should have said it but I guess what
I'll say is this did you end up having a
lot of deleted scenes yes and I'm not
releasing them this time yeah I've
changed my mind I've kind of realized
that it just produces all this what's
the movie is the movie I mean unless I
got unless if you see me do it again
I'll probably movie a movie where I felt
like I had to leave something behind
that I really didn't want to but that
the reality is that that this is the
best version of the movie we managed to
put together that's for sure what was
the last scene or two that you cut
before picture locking what almost made
the movie the there were no big scenes
that were cut as much as there was a the
last thing I really I I was torn about
but but was there was a beautiful piece
of Jon Bernthal at the Cloverfield
Airport where he does where the Mustang
thing is where he has a longer scene
with Matt when he takes him aside to
talk to him inside but I didn't think
the movie could wait any and we needed
to move along but it was a beautiful
piece of work by Bernthal and so it was
sad for me to cut but we have to talk
about the racing scenes Darren Prescott
I believe was your second unit
Darrin Jewett yes Darrin's done some
great work I'm curious talk a little bit
about collaborating with him and I'll
start with that and then I have a part
two well collaborating with him with
with Bob Nagel who was our stunt
coordinator with I mean one of the
things I'm really big on on my movies is
that everyone has their job and their
title but but everyone's allowed to get
in everyone else's [ __ ] like I don't
like turf I hate turf I hate like that
like don't touch my camera that's my
deal don't it like I and it exists on a
lot of movie sets but I like like if the
costume person has something to say
about the production design say it it's
like I want to hear all this stuff and
sometimes the prop guy will solve the
whole scene or the look or the or the
dressing or I mean that it comes from
any which way and so Darrin's brilliant
Bob Nagel is brilliant but as much they
were as much a part of it as all my
editor Mike mckusker was was on way
before we started shooting planning the
the Lamon and the other races we were
using previz using Matchbox cars on maps
using storyboards Gabe Hardman was this
brilliant comic book artist and also one
of the great storyboard artists around
and he did brilliant work at first
starting to lay out keyframes and and it
was a monumental effort on all sides
Darin came in after we kind of had a
version of the race
from beginning to end to help us figure
out how we begin to do it but all sorts
of other things come to play I mean
locations on my ad Adam Sumner a genius
I mean so much planning had to go into
figuring out to give you one example why
the the track at LeMond doesn't really
exist in any form like it did you know
in in the 60s so it's now kind of graded
and beautiful with the stands are
further from the track the it isn't what
it was which was so romantic and kind of
crazy which was just eight miles of
country
Rhodes varied that ran past the kind of
old-fashioned grandstand
and so this didn't exist in France
anymore and we had to somehow make it
and I mean that but we needed signature
places the Dunlop bridge the s is the
the the Molson straight there were all
these kind of signature sections of the
of the track that that any race fan
would recognize and and play a role in
how they're fighting through the race
and as well as obviously the grandstand
the starting and finish line and so we
shot almost all of the track in Georgia
most of that shot by Darren the mall the
like the exterior pieces on the cars
going under the Dunlop bridge or through
the esses or around the Mulsanne corner
or the Mulsanne straight and the white
house corner these were all hours and
hours apart from each other in Georgia
why well we had to find places that
matched what it really was but also
because you have to find places that
match that you also can get to and
they'll allow you to drive cars at in
excess of 150 miles an hour on so
because you're not looking entirely for
race track in many cases you're looking
for country road where you now like you
just think about all the details there
you have to work out you need like four
or five miles of straightaway country
road with poplars down this side also it
kind of matches France and then you need
all the people in the area to agree to
allow you to drive race cars at 200
miles an hour down there the country
roads and no one has to go at the wrong
time to check their mail or they're
gonna get impaled right so the the
there's a lot of coordination and then
all this that now so you have four or
five locations in Georgia we built in
acqua.dolce here we built the grandstand
and at an airport in acqua.dolce so
every time you see any one of the cars
do a full revolution around the track
you're seeing them leave acqua.dolce
california as they pass under the Dunlop
bridge they're in Atlanta and then
they're as they head to the mall send
straight there six hours away in another
location in Georgia and
as they round the turn again White House
corner is yet another location in
Georgia then as they approach the grants
in their back in aqua Dulce California
and on and on and on now that means that
when it's raining when it's noon light
when it's Twilight when it is night when
it's a wet down whatever it is has to be
shot to match in all of these locations
the positions of the cars have to match
in all of these locations the relative
speed of these cars have to match in all
these locations the dirt level we had
graded on the cars from a 1 to a 5 they
obviously the cars started a zero
completely clean and then they get up to
a 5 then it starts to rain and they go
down to it too so the the all of this
had to be planned charted ours ours
continuity people our prop people or I
mean it's a monumental effort and so and
we previous what we could we planned
what we could we assign all the numbers
and color categories to every shot but
it's a it was really complicated and in
a kind of magic of movies that you feel
like these cars are driving around a
continuous circle which they're not of
course I don't think anyone in this
theater realized what went in to doing
that are you releasing some sort of like
featurette to like explain I think we
have that V s I'm not against all DVD
extras but the III I'm not even against
extra scenes I just didn't do it with
this but the but the but yes I think
they made several things that detail
this and show the the previous which was
kind of pre edited because also as
you're working on the movie now you have
kind of we make this previz with those
of you know or don't know it's kind of
like a crude cartoon we make of what the
race will look like and then as we're
shooting our editors mike and drew start
to plug in the shots we've gotten and
then keep the car tuned for the shots we
haven't gotten so you can kind of see
this this quilt slowly assembling of the
pieces you need and the pieces you
haven't gotten and and by the end of the
shoot I was gathering you know I could
see where we still needed things and we
we tried to do those in acqua.dolce like
pick up whatever we had felt like we
hadn't gotten when we were in Georgia
and
and so did and Darrin was working there
as well shooting whenever I'd be like at
lunch he'd be suddenly out at the
airport or wherever just doing
loop-de-loops I wanted to ask before I
open it up to the audience how did you
talk about the cars and getting the cars
there and was the insurance on this
movie a hundred million dollars
no the well I don't know what the
insurance the movie was but but the cars
I mean there were days at the Ferraris
shop there were days we had several
thirty million dollar cars on the set
but we couldn't between takes you know
the owner would put a ribbon and cones
around it and the but we couldn't drive
those I mean obviously we we were
wrecking these cars on a daily basis and
thrashing them all so I mean they're
bumping into each other in railings into
camera cars and and also just getting
thrashed by how hard we were driving
them and as the cars got thrashed in
Lemont and we had a continuous body shop
we had a continuous obviously a garage
running continuously and these cars are
being rotated through it but they're
reproductions I mean we couldn't I mean
it's just not possible it you could you
can't drive a 1965 you know you can't do
it any one of these cars they'd be worth
hundreds of millions of dollars and
you're not gonna race him around track
so we we built all new yeah I did you
did you when you do something like this
you put it in your rider I'd like to
take one of these home I thought about
it and then then I got in one and
they're miserable they're there I mean
the gt40 is like the most uncomfortable
I mean it's it's a coffin it's the
windshield is in your face here it's not
like we all think of sports cars as
these things with nineteen point
adjustable seats and you know whatever
that's not this this is like a go-kart
with a with a sheet metal seat and some
crummy vinyl pad on it and the most
basic controls and then an engine the
size of that takes up the whole car and
drives you I mean you feel like you're
in
piece of aluminum foil writing and you
know 150 miles an hour and that's why so
many drivers died everything was really
just about strapping a man to an engine
and and encasing him no thought was
about crash zones or roll bars roll bars
and we're in fact installed after Ken's
death but there were no no one even
thought of just putting a simple bar to
keep the chassis from crushing the
driver until it happened lots of times
it is crazy to think what those athletes
and those people did back then I mean
it's crazy it's unbelievable
I'm definitely gonna open it up to the
audience so this is the is this on can
you all hear me it's called the catch
box so I'm gonna throw it at people and
let's see what we got in the audience
Peter miles how much a good amount
especially with Christian he spent a lot
of time with Christian before we shot
and also talked to Katrina Bal who
played Molly his mom and and then he
he's seen the film and has been and is
very pleased I think a very pleased and
but a lot I mean a lot of the a lot of
any characters we could get get anywhere
near who were actually there we got to
there's another Jack McMullen plays
Charlie a Kapoor who is actually a
Bentley dealer in Beverly Hills now who
was um Jack is the the kind of little
kind of Scottish guy with the thick
black hair greased back he was 19 at
LeMond that year and and he they brought
him along to France and he's now a
mature man selling Bentley's and in Los
Angeles but he remembers all that and
was on her set all the time and helped
us a great deal in fact our wardrobe in
many cases guys like Charlie brought
they had kept in their closet all these
years what they wore and they brought it
to our they brought it to our costume
department and they manufactured you
know perfect effect similes of what it
was for our whole pit crew and any many
our screenwriters Jezz and John Henry
talked to Carol
before he died I didn't get a chance to
and but on and on and on a lot of our
drivers were the sons of well known
drivers and brought their stories even
Darren and Nagel knew a lot of these
people and new stories I mean we had a
tremendous amount of wealth of knowledge
the toughest thing you have when you
make a real life story honestly is
there's the age-old battle of what's
most interesting and what's true and
trying to find the balance of that but
there's also the fact that what's true
is the deeper you dive into anything I'm
sure you've all found this in yours
areas of expertise the deeper you dive
into anything the more you realize there
are so much multiple versions of what is
true meaning that you people don't agree
on what happened and they remember it
differently and not coincidentally they
all remember it in ways that make them
the greatest hero of their story and the
so you end up having to play a role as
you're constructing a movie like this in
which you're trying to thread the needle
through what seems to you most likely it
happened as opposed to because the
stories don't all line up but also don't
you have to balance the truth with when
you're making a two-hour or a little
over two hour movie like you're making a
movie but you're also trying to be as
honest as you can to what really
happened yeah my goal is to is to create
like like movies are not really the best
format to get your history so that the
the my job at first is I think but I do
think I have a role we're saying it's a
true story so I can't be present I can't
make [ __ ] up but I also can't I feel
like the thing I can best do is make you
feel like you knew these people
you knew this place you get the tone of
the of the world in a way that you know
whenever they're in a documentary
they're performing but what were they
like when they you know what is Carroll
Shelby like which Carroll has his kind
of cal worthington anything thing he
does when he's on camera but what
happens when Carroll isn't on camera
what is it like and so I'm trying to
capture something you wouldn't get in a
you know a promotional video or
interview where someone like I am right
now is controlling what you see of me
I want to know what they're like in the
kitchen making an egg sandwich you know
that's what I mean that's what the
movies best at you know in a way can you
throw right there no I'll go right there
in a second do you talk into this thing
however that's very good there okay
hi James Tom Staller Finnish motorsport
magazine very entertaining movie right
off the bat thank you how much did you
know about motor racing going into this
and what do you know now and second part
of the question is did you go back and
look at some of the epic films from the
60s and early 70s like Lamar of course I
mean that's easy and Frankenheimer's
Grand Prix that's my favorite the last
one yeah okay economics but the yes not
only that but there was recently
released I think and we got a lot of it
all these b-roll and extra footage from
LeMond from McQueen's movie there was
all this other footage that they never
got used that was really amazing and for
a moment when we're trying to figure out
how to make the movie cheaper we thought
well do we use this stuff and I just I
don't think it ever works when you try
and combine old stuff and new stuff it
always looks like sad to me like yeah it
looks like old stuff and new stuff and
your other questions we're motorsports
and what did I know before and after
very little I learned almost anything I
know about Motorsports I learned making
this movie doing the interviews and
doing the and and but I don't think it
hurt me in a way for those of you who
aren't into Motorsports like I think
that not my angle on the movie or my
journey making the movie was one of
trying to figure out not only did I not
know much I did not find it that
interesting meaning I I mean I found the
cars the design beautiful and I loved
gear like I'm I came up making movies I
loved lenses I loved gear and I can see
how people get into cars in terms of
getting into the gak and the gear and
and I can understand that but what I
didn't get was that whenever I watched
races
they seemed really boring to me and I
love sports but they seem boring to me
because they're essentially like and the
yellow car is out of the blue car and
the blue cars pulling into the pits and
the red cars getting ahead of the yellow
car the yellow cars falling back the
yellow cars getting back with a yellow
cars in the front again and it's like
why what like I have no Conda and then I
hear a bunch of older guys talking about
yellow car he's either having a problem
or yellow cars and it's like I'm never
in when i watch football I know the
quarterbacks hurt his knee and he's
trying to play through it I know when I
watched tennis I know what they're
fighting against or the injury they had
or why this serve is so hard for them on
this side when I watch motor sports I'm
just watching people guessing at what's
going on inside some commercial colored
bubble with all these stickers and first
of all I find that revolting just the
level of sponsorship has got enough
[ __ ] so I mean look how beautiful it
looked when they didn't smother it like
STP and Smuckers and every other [ __ ]
thing and and and but on top of that the
the we're at the Logan level of the Q&A
right the but but the other thing was
just that it made me realize what I
thought I had to do to make it
interesting which is I have to get
inside that chassis I have to get inside
that helmet I didn't even know why he's
downshifting why he's going into the
pits I want to get to what they can't do
on television which is which is
understanding what the driver and the
guys the pit and they're and also the
idea in that those days when they didn't
have a radio so there's no you could
send a guy out in the car you know
except for holding a chalk sign as he
passes by there's no way to communicate
to him at all this gets really
fascinating and I feel like it's such an
interesting world then to bring the
audience into because once they
understand the rules of it all I don't
mean the rules like the sporting rules I
also mean like the rules of the world
like that like just like you're making a
science fiction movie this world has its
own language in its own its own its own
protocols and that you once once I got
into all that which I have to do to do a
decent job which I hope you think I did
then then then that education is what
allows me to kind of make the movie
comment I will make my father was one of
the framers of the sports marketing
business which put all the stickers on
the cars I'm so sorry
no you know what I'm not offended you
made a great movie thank you James
all right before you throw that real
quick I have to say I'm actually of the
exact same opinion of you when I I love
sports as well and I've always wondered
watching in the circles you brought me
and I actually gave I gave a [ __ ]
watching these races because I you know
what I mean you took it you love the
characters yes and then you also
understand why they're doing I mean I
don't go to any level of it but you
understand you you get a sense of when
they're kind of you know using their
tailing another car and waiting for
their opportunity you're waiting for the
straightaway or not trying to burn out
too fast we're not trying to blow their
engine or whatever it is just at least
some awareness of what or what their
tour won't close which is true by the
way his first slap at LeMond his door
wouldn't close and I loved the I mean to
me the irony it was the kind of thing
like only you could never write that
you'd never have your great heroes
setting off and in the first lap of
their life it's like they can't close
the door of their car you realize most
people are gonna think this is Hollywood
[ __ ] like that
the door not closing yeah I give up on
those people most people why would that
be Hollywood [ __ ] it's not making
anyone look bad no but you know what I
mean like there anyway but whatever
everyone's gonna think something's
[ __ ] right I want to you go right
there yes how much was real and how much
was CGI you mean the whole amman you
mean the big last race yeah the cars are
all real on the part that's that CG is
is and we built the main grandstand so
you know when they're in the pits and
you're seeing the crowd above them but
when you look raking shots like like
like if I were shooting Matt here and
the crowd above him this would all be
real and real extras and if I were
shooting this way shooting
raking along it would be real it would
be real for another 100 or 200 feet and
then it would be a green screen and then
the magic of CG would extend and when
you're looking across the road the
opposite side we again had kind of a
front wall and extras for the first
couple rows but then obviously well not
obviously maybe for you but I didn't
have twenty thousand extras every day so
those stands filled with people the
closer people are real people and then
and the distance is being done by CG
sometimes also there's you know there's
rigging on the cars that the CG would
remove but the cars themselves we had we
shot real cars I think there's two shots
where other features like cars that have
been rescanned or something like that to
make something match but the we did all
this no that was the magic of what
Darren and his team did is we really
shot cars moving let's throw it right
over there hey doing good how are you
I'm great man fantastic movie I day
played on this for a little while so
it's really a pleasure where were you
where were you working I did the fight
scene and with with Matt oh right and
Christian and then did a couple of the
mountain scenes that we did up in
Lancaster yeah it was crazy hot and then
like yeah no one knows that the first
couple weeks though the whole opening
race at Willow Springs it was a hundred
and fifteen degrees and we were shooting
and I mean you have you you it's like I
watch it and I'm like you don't feel it
it's just it's just like it was so
brutal
there were like umbrellas flying
everywhere pop-up tents were just going
every which way it was it was wild wait
so what's the question question mutual
admiration for Bruce Springsteen a
couple years ago I read this article or
something an interview with you saying
yeah this fantastic idea of a film in
between born run and darkness on the
edge of town and I loved it I've always
envisioned something like that
and I am so curious to know if that's
still an interest in you and
yeah yeah I could tell and and also uh
what is it about Bruce and his music and
his poetry that inspires you and keeps
you going
what's interesting question he was a
huge part of my artistic experience and
the and and and teaching me how to write
I think he's a great storyteller I mean
there's some people who tell stories and
songs and other people sing about kind
of conditions you know there's there's I
always think there's two kinds of songs
the songs are someone's telling you like
don't do this or always do that or it's
like advice songs and then there's the
songs where someone's just telling you a
story and Springsteen is I mean
Springsteen's influenced by other great
people but the because growing up on the
East Coast in in the 70s and 80s when he
came when he when he was coming into
being and making all those great albums
though those songs are a great lesson in
writing and how little you need is what
what to me was is the great lesson of
Springsteen is how economically you can
tell a story and how for us those of us
who were writers how hard we try to
avoid sometimes just telling a story I
met a little girl and I settled down in
a little house out on the edge of town
we got married and swore we'd never part
but little by little we drifted from
each other's hearts story
what 21 words the word little appears
four times but it doesn't matter it's
like it's not colorful I don't know the
color of the sky I don't know what the
clouds were like I don't know the color
of the house who gives a [ __ ] I know
it's a story of heartbreak and I know
it's a story where they went in with one
idea about where they were going and
life betrayed them something betrayed
them and and it's so few words and so
often we get in the way of emotion and
not only that but the other thing
to go on this digression with you is the
other thing I love about Springsteen is
we're in an age of irony we're meaning
it and feeling it is not cool it's so
much easier to make fun of [ __ ] than it
is to do [ __ ] and everyone makes whether
it's Twitter or YouTube or just the way
people talk
people are just knocking down [ __ ] all
day long but what have you [ __ ] made
and and and that to me Springsteen
represents someone who's who's who's
telling stories about feelings and
feelings are less cool right now you
know I mean the fact that this movie is
called old-fashioned is as much a result
of how far we've traveled into the age
of irony than it is anything else
because it's just it's just like it's
just that I think you get what I'm
saying
yeah let's go let's go all the way to
the back right over the stolen cars
amazing by the way
what's that stolen car yes great movie
Leo Beebe was he a real character and
was he that much of a dick well yes he
was a real character um I I mean Josh I
think gave him some there was some
special sauce with Josh that I think
made him extra extra annoying but the
but he did do what he did he did slow
Ken down he did decide that a tie or the
three cars crossing together would be
better for Ford than Ken winning by
several laps and and he knew how much it
meant to him and he'd they did at Ford
Beebe and others have anxiety about Ken
as a driver he was left behind the first
time they went there was theirs so I do
think that there were more people that
Beebe ended up representing probably
what several more cynical or kind of
corporate minded executives were feeling
but I also feel like you know the way
you tell a narrative I'm a big believer
in writing that there is no bad guy
like if there's anything I could tell
you as a writer other than right every
day that's important about writing is is
that don't use bad guy talk or villain
talk it will screw up your movie that
like everybody's got a reason everybody
you know Leo Beebe was a company man he
actually if I took he went to war with
with Henry for the second they were they
they were in the service together they
came back he was like his younger
brother who wasn't his younger brother
he was very protective of henry ford ii
their company was floundering the whole
reason they went to LeMond and spent all
this money was not to win a race really
what was publicity to sell cars so in
the end is leo be be a villain or is he
just pursuing why he came there which is
to get publicity for his company and
that's why they did it and and is it
naive of us to wish for them to be
something they weren't but i do it is it
was amazing to me that was one of the
reasons i did the movie was when i got
to the point reading the story where i
realize also when you guys see this the
poster I'm sure everyone thinks oh yeah
and the underdogs are gonna take it for
you of course and it's like that there's
something different about the way this
story unspooled that there's something
unique about the relationship of
Commerce and art or Commerce and sport
and that that the reality made that more
interesting made the story more
interesting to me because it wasn't just
you know another it wasn't Rudy with
cars you know I think we're basically
out of time is but I want to do you mind
doing like a lightning you took you give
long answers but I want to see if we can
do I'll try and do a lightning round
right so a lightning round means like we
try to go through some questions really
fast so you want to throw right there so
the idea is fast questions fast answers
and good throws yes and good throws all
right Henry Ford that was a great
character what was the like casting that
and I love Tracy Letts he was I wanted
him
the first choice for it I was thrilled
that he did it he's a great actor great
writer too and I thought he did an
amazing job especially in the scene
where he's driving you're not you're
[ __ ] up the lighthouse sorry I'm sorry
it's my fault you're right a quick
question some of your movies you write
and direct and some of them it seems
like you step in in a process that's
already ongoing how does that change
your process well all the movies I
reckon someone get credit I mean I don't
mean I'm the sole writer I just mean I
never stop tweaking scenes rewriting
scenes or even screenwriting but in the
until only about five years ago the
threshold for a director to get writing
credit was higher than a writer they've
changed that but in my past there's
there's movies that I don't have writing
credit on where I would have passed the
threshold to get the credit now but
didn't then but it's but um I'm editing
it's writing directing his writing
writing his writing acting his writing
again Turf not a big believer in it yes
sir thank you I want to ask you recently
agreed with Macquarie about new
filmmakers new filmmakers is based like
a lottery for them and then he later
said like it's basically almost no
lottery at all and I was just curious if
you were a new filmmaker now or now what
would you do to try to achieve success
from scratch Chris's point had nothing
to do with a lottery Chris's point was
well he meant the lottery like probably
other chances yes a winning that's that
that it's like when you watch some sad
soul buying a roll of those stickers in
the those tickets in the gas station for
the young screenwriters who are asking
how can I get my script in the right
place
you're the equivalent to Chris of the
person buying on the scratching scratch
things that his point is and it's
entirely in alignment with me is if
you're trying to make it in any craft
apply your craft I mean I can't tell you
how many people I meet who wrote one
screenplay and then they start going
about selling their one screenplay and
it's like imagine if you were a
carpenter and you were in Vermont and
you made one chair and then you left
your work place and you traveled with
your chair
to New York to sell your one chair and
and then it was like it was that all you
did and it's like yeah isn't it
beautiful and and it's like well why do
you make more of them and that that to
me there's this and it's fueled by the
fact that we read sorry this is
interesting to talk about the the fact
that we read about people getting famous
and successful really fast and we watch
all these people get rich doing [ __ ]
on the internet and then getting rich
really fast and we get jealous and we
want to have success really soon but if
you love filmmaking or if you love
whatever craft you have why do you want
to be successful really soon with
whatever [ __ ] you can make now if you
know you could be better later why do
you want to get it's only the kind of
the the Kardashian mentality that has us
trying to get to someplace before we're
even ready to do anything with it
because I just got to make my score I
got to get in the door no you got to
make your [ __ ] good like because the
what Chris is saying is that if your
work is undeniably good every door will
open you don't have to you don't have to
scratch any tickets you don't have to
worry about the doors will open people
go did you see that thing that kid made
get him in here as opposed to you
knocking at all and and that there's way
too much calculation about how I can
play the system as opposed to how about
I just make [ __ ] that is so [ __ ] good
that people just go that's really good
and tell everyone else about it and
that's what Chris was talking about guys
I got something real quick too that just
mainly he was on the podcast of the
Brian Koppelman recently yeah and he was
saying how he feels like he didn't he
didn't direct usual suspects and
basically he feels like he's trapped now
and like ever since he failed with a
wave the gun that that he's not taking
as like a serious director basically
he's you gotta get to talk to him about
you know basically I was like do you
feel like that he's fine yeah so like
good direct right away from themselves
instead of like just handing it off
whatever it is Chris said everyone has a
path I wrote Oliver and company like we
all have pasts
[Music]
let's just throw it right over here
because I think we got a rap was just
one amazing this movie my hands are like
sweating from watching these racing good
but I I have I've kind of become an
advocate for the stunt community and I
recently saw a article where Jon
Bernthal I don't know if I'm saying his
right
yeah stood up for stunts and he was
acknowledging the stunt community and
saying that they should be recognized
with an Oscar category of their own I
was wondering what your opinion was of
that I think would be great I just don't
know how you'd I think the trickiest
thing is just the way most of the craft
Oscars work is that just goes the one
with the most that attracts the most
attention so that it's kind of it's just
but I'm totally in support of anyway
that the stunt the stunt community gets
honored and in fact toward that in
regard to this film you know cuz
everyone always asking did how much did
the actors do as little as we could have
them do as possible honestly then we
want they have families and we want them
to go home to them and they're not
trained drivers they're very good and
very skilled but you you know if you're
not supposed to text and drive
you're certainly not supposed to act and
drive and and you're certainly not
supposed to act and drive ed 100-plus
miles an hour so this is this movie is a
magnificent amount of work by incredibly
the dead I mean we had some of the
greatest drivers in the world assembled
driving these cars and and even when you
see Christian behind the wheel it's not
green screen but it's it's Christian in
this vehicle we built called the buck
the but the biskits it and we also had
one called the buck but the biskits
where a stunt driver would be sitting
either on top of the car or in the rear
driving for him the controls were were
subsumed to another a place on the car
and so he was in a car that was you
could pan almost 300 degrees and not see
any gear and it looks like he's driving
but he's not driving command and control
of the car is elsewhere as it should be
and having a professional focused on
nothing but that's why you can see the
other cars right out his window as he is
moving at high speed past other stunt
drivers slaloming through because we've
choreographed all that but he's not
actually guiding his vehicle that's a
guy with the radio talking to everyone
else making sure everyone's safe
[Music]
athletes against commerce and art
artists against commerce in the same way
kind of what's hard it's hard the whole
entertainment industry is tough world I
was gonna say that uh I especially
enjoyed the pathetic fight scene between
Damon and Bale which was also
choreographed by the way but
choreographed pathetically yes on that
note I really want to commend you for
making one of the best films of the year
thank you Steve I really mean that a
huge huge thank you to IMAX and 20
Century Fox for being awesome partners
and letting us screen the movie early
and especially I thank you - James
mangle for coming out and doing this Q&A
thank you thanks for the great question
still really interesting thank you
[Applause]